[Music]
lynn is with us lynn is in tulsa
oklahoma how are you lynn
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so uh several months ago my kids and i
and my husband were in a car in an
accident and we are getting a settlement
my kids especially
are going to be getting
a good settlement and i'm wondering what
is the best way to go about saving match
okay um
are they
is everybody okay
yeah
yeah
i'm glad
so there's is there any ongoing medical
need
or uh future surgeries that we need to
set money aside for
surprisingly no go ahead okay
all right and so what is the uh what do
you think the size of this is going to
be what have they indicated
my youngest child
is going to be getting
about
a hundred thousand and then we have
about 000 in medical bills
for him for him
and then the other kids it's gonna be a
couple thousand
okay
but is he is he got a permanent
situation from this or
no it was just um
when it happened
my kids like my kids are here because
it wasn't their time to go
like i believe that
and we were really yeah we were really
blessed it was an auto it was a
pedestrian auto accident
um
and
my kids were we were the pedestrians
and um
but your baby got a hundred i had fifty
thousand dollars in medical bills but
it's completely healed
yes wow thank you lord okay yeah it
doesn't make sense to the world but i
know it wasn't his time to go yeah i i'm
i'm more than comfortable with that and
i'm also glad for him and you yeah this
is but i just i'm thinking about how to
allocate the money so the bottom line is
we don't need to allocate the money for
anything you've already covered the 50
000 medical bills or the 50s coming out
of this hundred
that's coming out of the hundreds okay
all right and the others are going to
get a handful of dollars all right now
yeah this is coming through an attorney
in a settlement process i assume
correct okay
in more cases than i like the court will
dictate to you what you can invest this
in
i don't like it because i think the
parent should be allowed to decide what
to invest for their own child instead of
the judge being the parent but a lot of
judges will take the position that the
parents are idiots and so they must be
prote they must be the child must be
protected from their idiot parents
investment
i disagree with that on a lot of levels
morally legally and everything else but
it doesn't matter the judge may tell you
you have to put it in something stupid
like just a cd
it may not even keep up with inflation
if you do that okay if you have the
option
this child is not going to need this
money until they're grown
no he's not then i would set the money
aside in a mutual fund i'd get with a
smart vester pro and pick a series of
mutual funds it's how i invested my own
kids money that i invested for their
college so why wouldn't i invest this
kind of money there
where it came from doesn't matter what
matters is that they don't need it for
20 years
or so
and what matters is that um
you know we need to outpace inflation
right
right and it's
i'm i know you know with interest
hopefully you know he'll have a good
chunk when he's 18 because he's only two
now so he has several years
and so i'm trying to also figure out how
to best
teach him
to use it wisely so he doesn't turn you
know get it when he's a certain age and
be dumb yeah
don't don't number one don't let him be
surprised that it's there
um it's like sex don't wait till they're
20 to tell them
exactly because they'll mess the whole
thing up
you know and so we need to talk about it
age-appropriately we don't slam a
three-year-old with too much information
right right but we do teach a
three-year-old something's happening
right there's something there and so
money we're gonna teach the kid how to
handle money because we expect them to
have some by the way we're gonna do that
with all your kids
this is what rich people do they teach
kids how to handle money
age-appropriately we don't make the
five-year-old go to the salt mines but
we do teach them to work because they
need to call ken coleman for a career
later right that's right absolutely and
i think i think dave i think this is
great advice too is as you walk him
along and the others uh you know at some
point they may talk and he got more of a
settlement than they did so i think this
is you know telling everybody in the
kids this is not some big secret this
was something that happened because what
you don't want is resentment
to grow either so i think this is
probably need to be more
transparent than normal it's the only
way extra conversations and extra
communication
shut down uh all kinds of things because
this
a horrible event and
is it is a part and and the survival of
it
the miraculous survival of it is uh part
of your family story now yeah and so
we're going to tell that we're going to
tell that story
not to continually bring up trauma but
it's uh it's god's hand on our life yeah
and it's part of the story it's part of
who we are at our house and part of it
was a little one got hurt worse and got
more money and that's just the way life
worked
and so yeah you go ahead and talk about
that i wouldn't surprise the siblings
either that he's getting some money when
he gets there or she gets there right
we've already told him you know where
you guys will be getting some money but
we're not yeah we don't need to talk
about it look we didn't talk about what
the ramsey net worth was until our kids
were grown and we started talking about
estate planning with them
you know like when they were in college
we started talking about it but we you
know they knew we had some money but i
didn't want them running around school
going but there are those bigger net
worth and you're dead and the community
we live in that's kind of a thing so um
you know i i i just want to think well
we're just working stiffs and uh we are
working stiffs we just did really well
and so i wanted but i wanted them to
feel the responsibility of it after i
had built their character on saving
giving working spending wisely
throughout their whole years so by the
time i turned this on him and we started
that meeting with as for me and my house
we serve the lord so this is actually a
responsibility to manage god's resources
for his glory it is not you hit the
lotto
and so when they see the number they
actually kind of felt the weight of the
number
uh instead of
uh whoo-hoo
i i can be in a reality show now that's
right i'm stupid and my parents have
money and so you know uh that kind of
stuff right and so they
didn't they didn't have that reaction
and none of my three did but again it
was a gradual
increased
process through the years so i would
invest it in mutual funds and i would
you know just
age appropriately begin to reveal that
it's there to where by the time we get
there you're not afraid he's going to go
crazy or she's going to go crazy and
head off to
the caribbean and do cocaine or
something because he suddenly got a
bunch of money i mean it's just you know
we're gonna fix all this ahead of time
so my friend andy andrews says we're not
raising kids to be great kids we're
raising kids to be great adults
and that's really the target here that's
where we're going